but I think 911 was a like a bolt of
lightning that illuminated the landscape
and that allowed us to see more vividly
trend lines that were happening before
but that we were most Americans were
oblivious out before nine eleven people
imagined that Americans lived in a
security bubble in which bad things
happen over there we watch them on TV
but not really here 911 brought home the
reality that now we live in a world in
which 19 men with very little money
basically living off their theft and
their other activity in the US were able
to kill twice as many Americans as the
Japanese killed in an attack at Pearl
Harbor so we live in a different world I
said I the way I explain to my students
has been a paradigm shift and most
people's mental a map hasn't caught up
with it in the old days we thought only
states could organize violence and kill
at the level of thousands or tens of
thousands in a single blow now we know
post 9-11 we should have known before
and those of us who studied it we're
talking about it well in advance of this
but now we know that a small group of
dedicated people if they are able to
assemble the means to kill can kill at
the level of states so we saw mega
terrorism on 911 we saw subsequent mega
terrorist attacks in other countries for
example the London subway bombing or
Madrid or Bali and I would say now
that's part of the world that we live
with now so today the risk of a single
nuclear bomb exploding in an American
city or in a city anywhere in the world
is greater than it was during the Cold
War during the Cold War we worried about
Armageddon that would be a nuclear war
in which all nuclear weapons would be
used and maybe everyone would have been
killed mercifully that's the likelihood
of that is declined dramatically with
the end of the Cold War
but ironically the likelihood of a
single nuclear bomb made by somebody
like the US or the Soviet Union during
the Cold War or Pakistan or North Korea
getting in the hands of somebody like
Osama bin Laden and exploding in one of
our cities has increased and I'd say the
likelihood of that over the past decade
since we've seen it since nine eleven is
mixed there's some positives and there's
some negatives al Qaeda has obviously
been significantly degraded but the
al-qaeda movement or the affiliates
remain quite substantial and the 911
haven't happened it's now the fact it's
been demonstrated it's possible for
terrorists to kill at the level of
thousand so I would say the dangers are
greater today greater today than they
were a decade ago
but that most people don't don't realize
it but one month to the day after nine
eleven the u.s. believed there was a
live nuclear bomb in New York City about
to be exploded here a source reported to
the US and George Tenet who's director
of CIA reported to President Bush that
al-qaeda had a small nuclear bomb and
had it in New York City and might be
about to explode it and after a period
of kind of catching breath there was an
interrogatory in which the president
wanted to know well did L did the former
Soviet arsenal have bombs of the
description that help that dragonfire
had given the answer yes we're all these
weapons adequately accounted for answer
no could al Qaeda have acquired one of
these weapons in heaven in New York and
be about to explode it and we not know
anything about it answer yes there was
no basis the conclusion of this was no
basis in science or technology or logic
for denying dragonfires report that
there was now a live bomb in New York
and on that basis the President ordered
the vice president leave Washington
because it's thought that visa might be
a bomb in Washington as well the nest
teams were these nuclear experts went to
New York to look for signs of
radioactivity it turns out and you can
read about it if you're interested that
it was a false alarm but what was was a
sharp reminder that the only thing that
stands between 9-11 3000 and a nuclear
911 which could kill 300,000 people or
more is the terrorists getting the
nuclear bomb or getting the material
from which they could make an elementary
nuclear bomb so the only difference
there's not intention not organized
capability since the 911 attack was well
into the zone of demonstrated
organizational competence it's just
they're getting their hands on a bomb
now let's pray and let's hope when this
work to make sure they don't get their
hands on the bomb but that's the issue
while it's not possible to prevent all
future terrorists attacks that will for
sure a hundred percent be future
terrorist attacks that kill Americans
here at home that you can write it down
put it in the back there were before
nine eleven actually to remember in
Oklahoma City just a decade ago a
homegrown American terrorists killed 162
children and and women and men at the
federal office building in oklahoma city
so we can't stop all newly all
terrorists attacks fortunately in the
case of the only terrorist attack that
could kill hundreds of thousands of
people in a single blow that is a
nuclear terrorist attack we can
successfully prevent it and it comes
from the happy syllogism from physics no
fissile material no mushroom cloud no
nuclear terrorism so all we have to do
all is a lot but all we have to do is
lock up all nuclear weapons and all
nuclear material as good as the gold in
Fort Knox to prevent terrorists not
being able to get nuclear weapons
Terrace can't make fissile material only
states can do that Terrace can't make a
nuclear bomb that's what states do but
if terrorists were to get a nuclear bomb
out of the Pakistani arsenal rather the
former Soviet arsenal or out of the pack
out of North Korea then with the
organizational capability that they've
demonstrated on 911 and the intent which
they've asserted over and over they
could envelop on the American city in a
mushroom cloud